[Music]
we had a job to do
we wanted to do it not let anyone down
he never ever thought we were not going
to come back
we survived and we're here to tell our
story
[Music]
[Music]
the battle raged in Normandy many lives
were lost the war must end in victory
and this must be the cost when my life
is over and I reach the other side I'll
meet my friends from Normandy and shake
their hands with pride
[Music]
as dawn broke on that gradual morning
the greatest Armada of ships the world
has ever seen
till the narrow waters of the English
Channel
where there's that one's a bit rough
[Music]
one dead faithful about
I realized then there was no longer an
exercise in detail the weather was so
bad in the sea conditions and I thought
about the troops and city in landing
craft but thinking about them
it's just sitting in there going across
in those rough conditions horrible
feeling against withering fire from
well-concealed German em placements only
the highest courage and determination
could avail I never give me the thought
- all I was concerned is keeping me head
down buying the orders you are the
sergeant or with you an officer yeah and
if they see jump you jump I mean I
couldn't please yourself
[Music]
everybody says really nervous
and we were young we meant we'd we never
ever thought we were not going to come
back having the results of the losses
that we had I mean that's I think most
people realize now that never said I
think there was a 110 thousand
bomber crews trained to fly operational
and 50,000 of those never came back
parachutists and airborne troops had
done their work well the much-vaunted
atlantic war was cracked and through the
crack what our main assault forces to
fight their way in I'll never forget the
people I'm braving those angry sky it
was exciting
I think mostly it wasn't necessarily fun
but it was exciting
on that first landing we hadn't seen any
enemy we did we'll get later on that
night that particular point we were
landing in a foreign country
everything was with new and exciting I
sometimes hear them say
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it was a different world then it it it
was the world that required young men
like myself to to be prepared to die for
for a civilization that was worth living
so there was a very heavy necessity
young men like me to say that I had put
my life on the line my life wasn't on
the line today and I I jump because I
believe that God wants me to John
[Music]
none of them wanted to be part of
another wall but when the test came when
freedom had to be fought for or
abandoned they fought they were soldiers
of democracy they were the men of d-day
and to them we owe our freedom
[Music]
we appreciate very much that thought the
country thinks about what we did my
contribution was very very small we all
thought you know we've done our training
we had a job to do we wanted to do it
not let anyone down and we hope to come
out in one piece
[Music]
you really think of it often in your
life you know I'm probably near darker
moments when your name behind of
something that's when just do these
things as you get older you do a lot of
things in bed really you know but you do
think of it but it's so worthwhile to
come here it's like a promise almost too
than we are now
it's almost like we're here we survived
and we're here to tell our story and
there's Lance that came with us still 18
and 19 and 20 they're lining the ground
over there
sometimes I wonder who picks the ones to
die and who picks the ones to survive so
I feel very privileged unfortunate to
think that our mine in those lives of so
what we should do now is remember them
[Music]
my most abiding memory of that day is a
seed our boys we've been talking to the
minutes before but they were cut down
with machine-gun fire was pretty bad a
lot of time they fall into the water
floating facedown and we couldn't get
them out we couldn't get we couldn't
help them and that is my most abiding
memory and I can't forget in
Thank You Phyllis me
[Music]
you
[Music]